So in this problem set, we're going to try to plot the trajectory of the spaceship
by creating functions for its acceleration and its trajectory.
We'll start it out with some helpful information. We'll set the step size to 1 second.
I told you the mass of the earth and giving you the gravitational constant,
which you might recognize as G from the equations in other videos.
We've also already created arrays for you for position and velocity, which right now
are filled with zeros and set the initial position and the initial velocity of the spacecraft.
Now, I'm going to remind you of some information that you've already learned
that's going to be especially helpful for this problem.
We talked earlier about the equation for the gravitational force between two objects
that's what this little g here next to the F for force stands for gravity.
This big G in the equation is this gravitational constant that we've given you in the code
that's multiplied by the mass of the earth and the mass of the spacecraft
and this is divided by the distance between the earth and the spacecraft squared.
Now, this d with a hat over it represents a unit vector that any given vector
has a unit vector associated with it.
This unit vector, which is denoted by this hat over top of it,
is equal to the original vector itself divided by that vector's magnitude.
So this d with a hat over it up here shows us that the gravitational force
has this magnitude and is pointing in this direction,
which is a line pointing from the earth out to the spaceship.
Now, if you look back at the code for a second, you'll see that this function that we're asking
of you to find is actually for acceleration not for force,
but we know that force and acceleration are very intimately related by Newton's second law,
which is that force equals mass times acceleration.
This means in the case that we're considering right now we can find the acceleration of the spaceship
by simply taking the equation for force that we just read out and dividing by the mass of the spaceship,
which leaves us with this expression right here.
Your job is to translate this equation into an expression in Python for acceleration
and then to use that expression along with the information we've given you in a
Forward Euler Method to describe the position and velocity of the spaceship at any given timestep.